it's coming up to 20 past 4 let's go
back to our top story and bring you an
update from Essex Police
it's the horrible story that came out of
theracane Essex this morning 39 bodies
discovered in the early hours of the
morning in a lorry at an industrial park
police are now saying they believe the
trailer traveled from Zeebrugge er into
Purfleet and docked in the thorak area
shortly after 12:30 a.m. this morning
the tractor unit of the lorry is
believed to have originated in northern
island sky knees understands this
afternoon the 25 year old man who has
been arrested on suspicion of murder
his mo Robinson from County Armagh a
crime correspondent Martin brunt is
outside Gray's police station more
details emerging Martin you're putting
them all together what can you summarize
for us it's confirmation in the last few
minutes really from what we've been
reporting in the last half an hour and
it's really more clarification or more
detail of the arrival of that trailer in
which those bodies were found at 1:40
this morning police originally
suggesting that the cab and the trailer
had traveled in the last four days from
Holley head in North Wales but it's now
been established that the trailer with
those bodies on board arrived this
morning at around 12:30 having traveled
from on a ship from Zeebrugge er in
Belgium to Purfleet and docked at around
half past midnight this morning and then
was picked up connected to that red cab
unit and then driven the short distance
to the industrial park at Gray's where
it's thought to have arrived sometime
after shortly after 1:00 o'clock this
morning and we've already been told that
the alarm was raised about half an hour
later and the driver 25-year old man
from
Northern Ireland was arrested now it the
police are saying nothing about how the
alarm was raised police say they learned
from the ambulance service that there
was this emergency and the bodies had
been discovered and it does rather
suggest perhaps it was the driver
himself who alerted the authorities now
we're naming the driver as mo Robinson a
25 year old man police aren't confirming
that but we understand that mr. Robinson
is a lorry driver from near Porter down
in Northern Ireland in fact on his
Facebook page he describes himself as a
lorry driver and also on that Facebook
page there are a number of images of
lorry cabs including most recently a red
cab unit that matches appears to match
the red cab unit that was attached to
that trailer that contained the 39
bodies this morning mr. Robinson is
still in custody police will have
something like up to four days to
question him but clearly he would appear
to be best placed to give police more
details of the journey of the trailer
and the cab he was driving